these people fled their homes three
months ago to save their lives
again took over their neighborhood some
of their homes were set on fire those
who resisted were killed
Sheila philu says they have nothing left
and need food desperately
hopeless or bring us anything all of
these people sleep here when it rains
were flooded any possibility we have to
leave the country will leave we're
living like animals this is the reality
for people in Haiti right now
violent gangs control more than 80
percent of the capital Port-au-Prince
these people have nowhere to go they
were forced out of their neighborhoods
because of the fighting going on between
rival gangs many have lost their
relatives they say they're desperate and
Afraid
Akin least 12 years old he's just one of
the dozens of children living here
we cannot find enough food my house was
burnt and so is my wheelchair my knees
hurt when I move
fighting and kidnappings are common
across the country the police are
outnumbered and outgunned prime minister
arielenry has requested International
assistance to help the government fight
the gangs the situation is a director
but the organization of American state
says deploying an international force is
not easy but it's difficult as well to
do those kind of things without a clear
mandate you know countries are very wary
of sending you know troops to sending
Security Forces abroad without a clear
International Monday that would give
them some kind of legal protection so
those are the things that are in a
discussion right now on the table the
willingness is there now we need to find
the house
at a government office in the center of
the city hundreds are lining up to get a
passport to leave the country
but finding a place to go is becoming
increasingly difficult every month they
have meeting about Haiti but what is
happening
nothing the Asian people right now need
to live in peace and everyone here want
to live in their country
millions of Haitians are in desperate
need of help
chaos has once again taken over their
lives and it seems unlikely the
situation will get better anytime soon
Prince